Це перша мобілізація у Росії після 1941-го року.
За часів афганської війни вона за фактом йшла, але офіційно не оголошувалася.
У середу Володимир Путін, ймовірно, щоб не викликати бурхливих протестів населення,
назвав свою мобілізацію "частковою".
Вважаю за необхідне підтримати пропозицію міністерства оборони та Генерального штабу
про проведення в Російській Федерації часткової мобілізації.
Одразу услід за Путіним по телебаченню виступив міністр оборони Сергій Шойгу,
який заявив, що у ході мобілізації призвуть 300 000 осіб.
Триста тисяч резервістів, які будуть призвані, хочу одразу сказати, що це не одноразово –
це та робота, яка проводитиметься планово.
Тим часом у Києві досить спокійно відреагували на рішення Путіна провести часткову мобілізацію.
Коментарі політиків у соцмережах мають радше саркастичний характер.
Так радник глави офісу президента України Михайло Подоляк написав:
Загальна тональність заяв, які лунають з Києва, - для українців мобілізація у РФ нічого не міняє.
Треба розуміти, що ці так звані резервісти значно гірше готові до війни,
ніж та армія, яка зараз воює проти України.
Ті сили, до речі, чиї залишки воюють з тих десь ста сімдесяти п'яти тисяч,
які починали повномасштабне вторгнення в Україну, і це найбоєздатніше, скажімо так, ядро російської армії насправді, -
це ж переважно контрактники, спецпризначенці чи найманці.
І якщо вони не змогли досягти якихось значних результатів, то я не думаю, що цим новим вдасться.
Перехожих, опитаних DW на вулицях Києва, новина про мобілізацію, схоже, теж не дуже схвилювала.
Путін пішов ва-банк. У нього великі втрати на фронті, і він пішов ва-банк.
Хоча в них там і так ця часткова мобілізація вже давно є прихована.
Тобто, по суті, нічого такого особливого не сказав.
Думаю, вони визнають свою поразку, що ми перемагаємо.
Ми з оптимальним духом ідемо тільки вперед, до перемоги.
Я думаю, що в них зараз почнуться вже якісь протести щодо цього.
Ну, а м'ясо (гарматне) хай приходить до нас.
Думаю, що це трохи нечесно, бо війни в них немає, а мобілізація є. Дуже цікаво виходить.
Тому чи вплине це на хід війни - ні, бо я вірю в Україну і не думаю, що якась ще одна купка людей,
які не розуміють, чому і за що вони сюди йдуть, на жаль, помирати, щось змінить.
Тим часом російські опозиційні телеграм-канали вже розповсюджують фотографії повісток у військкомат,
які почали масово отримувати мешканці Москви та Санкт-Петербурга.
При цьому вартість авіарейсів із цих міст до безвізових країн станом на середу досягла захмарних висот.
І навіть за такими цінами більшість квитків уже продано.
Однак перехожі на вулицях Москви реагують на питання щодо можливого відрядження на війну радше апатично.
Мені без різниці. Я людина проста. Скажуть - піду. Здохнемо всі. Хтось раніше, хтось пізніше.
У такі моменти завжди тривожно. У тебе є дружина, діти.
І ти думаєш про те, що якось залишати їх не хочеться, якщо раптом щось.
При цьому найбільш бойовий дух у тих опитаних, хто точно не підлягає мобілізації – за віком чи статтю.
Це ж наші люди. Ми їх маємо захищати. І маємо бути єдині у всьому.
Я вважаю, що це нормально.
Тим часом у Німеччині виступ Путіна розцінили як подальшу ескалацію війни з боку Кремля
і як вияв слабкості російського президента.
Для мене це ознака слабкості. Україну це не налякає. Нас це теж не повинно лякати.
Ми повинні налаштуватися на тривалий конфлікт з Росією.
Тому нам потрібно обговорити у колі союзників і партнерів,
як ми можемо підтримати Україну в іще довшій боротьбі за мир і свободу.
Думку політиків поділяють також німецькі експерти.
На мою думку, Путін показує ознаку слабкості.
Справа не лише в суті цієї часткової мобілізації, а й у тому, що він спочатку хотів вимовити промову, а потім відклав її.
У військовому плані справи в Україні у росіян виглядають не найкраще.
І я вважаю, що ця часткова мобілізація не допоможе йому.
Це, поза сумнівом, ознака слабкості. Врешті-решт йому не довелося б іти на цю ескалацію,
якби його військові тримали ситуацію під контролем, як він того хотів і уявляв. А це явно не так.
Невдачі російської армії величезні, вони накопичуються.
У військовому плані Україна, схоже, поступово притискає Росію спиною до стіни.
До того ж, експерти сумніваються, що це зможе змінити ситуацію на полі бою.
Збільшення чисельності російських військ на 300 000 солдатів - це багато.
Але користі від цього буде не так багато, як уявляє Путін.
Ви не можете раптово призвати потужні підрозділи, у вас просто буде юрба людей,
з яких ви не зможете швидко створити великі підрозділи.
Також не надто розумно впихати по кілька солдатів то тут, то там у деякі вже існуючі підрозділи,
які вже деморалізовані і, можливо, втратили значну частину свого спорядження.
Триста тисяч не можуть з'явитися одномоментно.
По-перше, на триста тисяч потрібно мати амуніцію, мати озброєння, мати забезпечення,
зараз іде зима, зимовий військовий одяг нормальної якості, якого бракує росіянам, хто б що не говорив, і багато чого іншого.
Тому я думаю, що це буде, знаєте, отаке-от підживлення окремих напрямків російськими силами на північ і на сході -
там десять-п'ятнадцять-двадцять тисяч від сили.
Досі Путін уникав оголошення мобілізації, оскільки це непопулярний крок серед населення.
І лише критична ситуація на фронті змусила його вдатися до цього, вважають експерти.
Це може спричинити зростання антивоєнних настроїв.
Активістські спільноти у різних містах уже закликають незгодних виходити на вулиці.
Приміром, громадський рух "Весна" закликав у соцмережах до масових акцій протесту проти мобілізації,
назвавши її "могилізацією".
Досі російському керівництву вдавалося підтримувати певну подобу нормального життя,
особливо у великих містах, таких як Москва чи Петербург.
Люди не відчували війни. З Москви та Петербурга майже не було жертв.
Але тепер завдяки цій частковій мобілізації ситуація зміниться.
Зараз війна справді входить майже до кожного будинку.
На фронт відправлять батьків та синів, а чоловіків зірвуть з робочих місць, щоб воювати в Україні.
Нині війну, безумовно, помітять у значній частині населення Росії.
Експерти зауважують, що слова Путіна були скеровані також на Захід.
Він пригрозив використанням ядерної зброї.
У цій ситуації Заходу важливо не піддатися путінському шантажу, переконані експерти.
Ці закони, а також постійні погрози, що він використовуватиме всі засоби,
включно з ядерними загрозами, є частиною психологічної війни.
І Путін та його режим дуже розраховують на певні сили тут, у Німеччині, а також у Франції та інших європейських країнах,
які вважають, що загальна мобілізація - це свого роду кнопка, натиснувши на яку Путін виграє війну.
Путін зараз слабкий. І я думаю, що найважливіший сигнал для всіх у Німеччині та Європі –
не лякатися цих законів, які не змінюють ситуацію у військовому відношенні,
не змінюють ситуацію для України і лише підкреслюють, що Росія
є авторитарною та тоталітарною системою зсередини.
У промові Путін також підтримав референдуми у так званих ЛНР і ДРН та на інших окупованих Росією українських територіях.
Псевдоголосування має розпочатися 23 вересня.
Західні лідери вже заявили, що не визнають їхніх підсумків.